bonjour et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction
édition de fin de semaine dans voici les
principaux titres le fait de transmettre
ou de diffuser sans le consentement de
la personne son image sa voix dès lors
qu'elle est présent qu'elle présente un
caractère sexuel sera passible de deux
ans de prison et de 60000 euros damende
l amendement a été voté fin janvier par
les députés retour sur cette loi vous
entendrez également le témoignage d'une
victime grâce partielle du président
françois hollande à jacqueline sauvage
cette décision va-t-elle faire avancer
la cause des femmes victimes de violence
pour en parler chantal paoli texier
présidente
agissez contre la violence basée à
maurepas et puis en seconde partie de
journal retour sur l'actualité est
développé sur notre antenne depuis lundi
david douillet élu à la tête des
républicains dans le département
réaction du préfet des yvelines à la
probable prolongation de l'état
d'urgence ou encore annonce de la
participation d'yves linois au prochain
vendée globe
la ministre de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie
dans les yvelines ce vendredi matin
ségolène royal était aux mureaux sur
l'un des sites d'airbus dédiée à la
défense et airbus leader mondial de son
secteur elle a assisté aux innovations
mises en place mais aussi au travail des
équipes de cryospace la groupement
d'intérêt économique dans la
construction aéronautique et spatiale on
écoute la ministre au micro de florane
parfait et fanny bondir tout
l'observation depuis l'espace de la
terre et du réchauffement climatique est
aujourd'hui indispensable
y compris en l'articulation d'ailleurs
ac et télécommunications puisqu'on est
dans la phase de transition et de
révolution énergétique et en même temps
de révolution numérique la question des
télécommunications et en même temps de
l'observation scientifique du
réchauffement climatique ce sont
vraiment des éléments clés à la fois
pour connaître les mécanismes et surtout
pour agir rapidement sur les mécanismes
climatiques
reportage complet à suivre lundi dans
notre journal à partir de 18h en direct
une autre information politique elle
concerne saint quentin en yvelines et
les tensions entre l'équipe majoritaire
de centre-droit et son opposition de
gauche le maire de la verrière le
communiste alain jaj a indiqué qu'il ne
souhaitait plus siéger au sein de
l'exécutif en raison je cite et d'un
refus de dialogue de l'équipe dirigeante
ainsi que l'obstination qui frise
écrit-il dans une lettre adressée à
michel laugier président de saint
quentin
l'humiliation ce dernier n'a pas encore
réagi
les députés ont donc voté fin janvier un
abonnement au projet de loi sur le
numérique qui prévoit le rivage sport
nous vengeance pornographie qui prévoit
que 7,7 cet acte soit passible de deux
ans de prison et de 60000 euros d'amande
au delà des conflits entre anciens
amants ce texte va aussi permettre de
mieux punir ceux qui piègent leurs
victimes sur des discussions intime sur
skype par exemple les explications et ce
témoignage avec michael et demi d'euros
le revendre sport nous la mise en ligne
d'une vidéo à caractère sexuel sur
internet et les réseaux sociaux est
désormais condamnée par la loi
la mesure a été votée le 21 janvier par
les députés dans les yvelines viennent
dujarrier pistard du club de vélizy 78 a
déjà subi un chantage à la vidéo par une
inconnue rencontrée sur les réseaux
sociaux une demande d'amis sur facebook
tout simple avec
des amis communs donc donc du coup un
petit peu moins d'un petit peu moins
méfiants
on a commencé à discuter à parler à part
les diverses choses
au bout d'un moment on nous met en
situation
compromettantes la personne se dénude
devant devant la devant la devant la
webcam alors que vaut mon dernier quoi
on est juste en train de discuter et la
personne se dénude quoi donc c'est le
piège le piège se referme très
rapidement une fois la vidéo
enregistrées via son écran l'inconnu
menace de la diffuser sur les plates
formes de partage si le pistard ne lui
verse pas d'argent mais l'yvelinois n'a
pas cédé je n'ai pas de lutter pendant
pendant très longtemps on n'use pas de
dix minutes un quart d'heure vraiment de
faire comprendre que moi je que moi je
ne cèderai pas à ceux à ce chantage
maintenant la vidéo était été posté donc
c'était le mal était fait la vidéo a
finalement été bloqués sur internet deux
semaines après les faits yann dujarrier
analyse cet épisode sort d'une dune
d'une rupture et ça récupère
actuellement je peux être un peu l'idée
de ce temple faible plus faible à ce
niveau là la loi sur leurs 25 prévoit
une peine de deux ans de prison et 60000
euros damende françois hollande a
accordé à jacqueline sauvage condamné à
dix ans de prison pour le meurtre de son
mari violent une remise gracieuse de sa
peine d'emprisonnement qui lui permet
donc de présenter immédiatement une
demande de libération conditionnelle
nous allons parler avec notre invité la
présidente de l'association agissez
basée à maurepas bienvenue sur ce
plateau exploit sociation spécialisé
dans les questions de violence morale un
jeu précises dans le cadre privé comment
vous avez accueilli 7 cette décision
cette grâce partielle du président tout
d'abord d'abord nous étions signataires
du manifeste pour la libération de
jacques une sauvage en tout cas pour
obtenir un autre regard sur son dossier
donc on ne peut qu'accueillir ça avec
avec joie pour cette femme
maintenant ça soulève encore beaucoup de
questions et de problèmes auxquels il va
falloir peut-être s'attaquer à présent
il ya vu un fort soutien populaire on va
repréciser le cas de jacqueline sauvage
elle avait tiré en 2012 trois coups de
fusil dans le dos de son mari donc après
avoir subi des violences de sa part
pendant 47 ans fort soutien populaire
mais aussi quelquefois des voix qui se
sont élevées contre cette demande de
grâce partielle aussi expliquant qu'il
ne s'agissait pas forcément là de
légitime défense ou encore que 47 ans
était largement suffisant pour exprimer
les difficultés qu'elle rencontrait ben
justement je pense que c'est là que le
bât blesse c'est que ce procès c'est
c'est aussi le désaveu enfin le désaveu
cesser la mise en abyme du fait que la
justice ne comprennent pas la notion
d'emprise et que 47 ans d'emprise sa
marque une femme sa marque toute une
famille
on sait que sa vie ont été victimes
voilà c'est fini son fils est le fils
est d'ailleurs suicide est juste avant
que sa mère n'assassine son père donc il
ya des corrélations qui aurait dû être
fait qu'ils n'ont peut-être pas été fait
je pense qu'au delà de
de ce qui s'est passé pour jacqueline
sauvage c'est effectivement toute la
question de la notion d'emprise et de sa
méconnaissance par la justice que ce
procès interpelle qui avait déjà été
interpellé par la faire l'ange
remarquablement défendu par le procureur
de douai
là en l'occurrence on est passé à
peut-être un petit peu à côté et je
trouve ça très regrettable
est-ce que ça va permettre de faire
avancer les choses fait voler sa
situation aussi bien dans l'opinion
publique que du côté de la justice c'est
ce qu'on espère c'est ce qu'on espère
parce que effectivement beaucoup de voix
se sont élevées pour justement montré
que c'était cette notion de l'emprise
qu'ils n'avaient pas été prises en
considération de de mémoire traumatique
de dissociation de la victime qui font
que les femmes oui elles n'osent pas
porter plainte c'est très très difficile
quand on est victime de violence d'un
pour cent seulement des femmes qui
pensent qu'ils portent plainte ce sont
les chiffres plus de 200 mille femmes
par an qui serait à victimes de
violences conjugales
on peut même si tu es encore d'autres
chiffres plus 134 c'est le nombre de
femmes mortes sous les coups d'un
conjoint violent sur l'année 2014
est-ce que vous avez constaté malgré
tout ces dernières années que la parole
se libérer un petit peu est-ce qu'on
puisse plus facilement la porte des
associations comme la vôtre alors la
parole se libère au niveau des victimes
je pense que l
elles font beaucoup plus de démarches
qu'auparavant pas forcément pour porter
plainte justement mais plutôt pour être
soutenus et accompagnés
maintenant toute la difficulté de la
procédure pénale reste encore quelque
chose qu'il faut vraiment travailler de
manière de manière beaucoup plus abouti
parce que même si le 78 le tribunal de
78 et très pointu par rapport aux
violences conjugales c'est ça reste
quand même très insuffisant et une femme
a vraiment du mal à proposer la pousser
la porte d'un commissariat ou une
gendarmerie à l'heure actuelle le
gouvernement a lancé il ya deux ans un
plan de lutte injustement contre la
violence qui sont faites aux femmes
visant notamment encouragé le dépôt de
plainte à des mesures qui ont été prises
dans la loi 2014 sur l'égalité femmes
hommes aussi ou encore le renforcement
des ordonnances de protection
généralisation aussi de ses téléphones
grand danger aussi qui devait permettre
qui permettent toujours d'appeler
rapidement les secours en tout cas
d'avoir une écoute est ce que ça a été
efficace
je saurais pas dire parce que nous on a
fait une seule demande de téléphones
grand danger et on ne l'a pas obtenue et
c'était un cas de harcèlement
donc je pense que les téléphones grand
danger qui ont été accordés dans 78 par
exemple ce que je peux me fier qu'à ça
c'est vraiment des femmes qui ont vécu
des violences physiques graves et qui
sont dans une situation de précarité en
plus alors que c'est vrai que nous le
public contre qui est concerné par les
violences morales c'est quand même les
milieux plus favorisés on va dire et des
femmes qui sont qui reste quand même
très démuni par rapport à ce qu'elles
peuvent faire donc
outre le dépôt de plainte c'est quelles
actions menées pour se libérer
est ce que c'est encore plus difficile
effectivement on peut re précisé
l'association existe depuis 99 vous
agissez effectivement sur ces questions
de violence morale sur le stalking le
harcèlement en fait là c'est encore plus
difficile à prouver
malgré le délit de harcèlement de la loi
du 9 juillet 2010 ça reste encore
un débat qui qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
suffisamment porté je dirais il part y
compris par les politiques y compris
projet de loi soutien non seulement un
projet de loi plus aboutie mais surtout
une application effectivement dès délit
de violence psychologique et de
harcèlement et est un travail un peu
plus approfondie autour de ces questions
là et puis surtout surtout une formation
une formation des magistrats des
professionnels de la santé des avocats
de des institutions parce qu'on voit
encore trop de dossiers malheureusement
nous c'est le constat que nous faisons
et que nous portons et fort que le droit
des victimes de violences morales est
absolument pas reconnu c'est parce que
la violence morale elle même n'est pas
reconnu donc au delà du pénal comme il
ya un défaut de dans ces dossiers
là on traite ces dossiers là sous forme
de conflit et on ignore totalement les
conséquences sur la mer victimes ce que
ce qu'il ya dans le projet de madame
sauvage c'est que justement cette mère
victime n'a pas été protégé du coup si
elle n'a pas été protégé ses enfants
n'ont pas été protégé et tout le monde
s'est tu et nous sommes dans c dans nos
dossiers
dans ces cas de figure ou alors par
contre des voix s'élèvent mais elles
sont pas entendus un peu différent mais
mais voilà c'est toujours ces questions
de soi vous bougez vos porté plainte et
venez pas entendu soit vous ne portez
pas plainte et on vous le reproche que
faire depuis un an à peu près 1 mars
2015 en france l'université paris 8
en partenariat avec le département de la
seine saint denis elle a proposé à des
professionnels du milieu social scolaire
juridico médical une formation inédite
en france c'est un diplôme bac + 3 de
politiques de prévention et de lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
j'ai découvert ça en faisant quelques
recherches pour ce plateau elle vous me
l'apprenez
est ce que ça peut être une bonne chose
oui bien sûr toutes les formations sont
bonnes à prendre
maintenant je pense que le méconnu
encore complètement oui je ne
connaissais pas et moi je pense que le
problème du phénomène d'emprise qui est
à l'origine de toutes les formes de
violence devrait justement être pris en
considération à part entière c'est à
dire qu'on devrait avoir des formations
uniquement sur sur la notion d'emprise
et ça bon ça met un peu de temps à
démarrer on va dire vers la question au
canada le pays et reconnaît la
présomption de légitime défense pour les
femmes qui sont victimes de violence et
non prise aussi qu'elles subissent
faudra la même chose en france
ça pourrait être une bonne chose en
regardant le dossier de madame sauvage
je me suis rendu compte que le procureur
avait opposé trois coups de poing
un nom un coup de poing à un coup de
poing à trois coups de fusil en omettant
totalement 47 ans de violences dans
pleased état de sidération
toutes les conséquences qui a lorsqu'on
est victime de violences conjugales
qu'elle soit morale physique qui est des
viols ou qu'ils aient pas de viol et là
du coup toute la question est posée
on peut pas opposer un coup de poing
lors c'est pas vrai à trois coups de
fusil
donc oui et bien légitime défense quand
on est au bout du rouleau et qu'on n'en
peut plus certes il vaudrait mieux que
les femmes portent plainte
il vaudrait mieux que l avoir des
associations mais en même temps on sait
que le parcours est tellement difficile
pour elle pour nous parce que les
associations un mal de mer les actions
hbos les associations beaucoup de mal à
survivre s'est pas posé la question est
ce que les choses aillent mieux pour
votre association
non c'est de pire en pire les
associations sont sans arrêt sans arrêt
sur la sellette giron n'a aucune
pérennisation on a beau sauver des vies
être d'intérêt public comme a fait
remarquer un sénateur mais à part ça on
se demande chaque fois si demain on va
pouvoir continuer et c'est toujours le
cas aujourd'hui donc c'est ça qui est
complexe et sacchi compliqué c'est on
les pousse à bout c'est la porte
effectivement d'associations pour ne pas
en venir à se défendre elle même mais
des associations qui ne sont pas là et
encore du chemin à parcourir
exact merci chantal politique c'est
d'être une source plage et vous invite à
jc contre la violence basée sur maurepas
merci encore à vous un tout autre sujet
à présent najat vallaud-belkacem la
ministre de l'éducation nationale de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et thierry mandon son secrétaire d'état
à l'enseignement supérieur et à la
recherche ont présenté cette semaine un
plan destiné à remettre les
bibliothèques universitaires au service
des étudiants ça peut paraître malgré
tout assez logique une extension des
horaires d'ouverture ainsi que le
développement de services numériques
seront les leviers pour désengorger les
établissements c'est ce qu'ils ont
annoncé quelles conséquences pour
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines par exemple les réponses
avec sephora nomade le plan national
bibliothèque est ouverte fixe des
objectifs précis ok les bibliothèques de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines répond déjà en
grande partie il est question d'ouvrir
au moins une bibliothèque dans chaque
université jusqu à 20
deux heures du lundi au vendredi
n'ouvrir également le samedi après-midi
et d'assurer une permanence pendant les
périodes de vacances scolaires les sites
de boulogne et de saint quentin en
yvelines propose déjà une large
amplitude horaire qui leur permet
d'arborer le label noctambu la
certification d'une permanence de plus
de 65 heures hebdomadaires à savoir
qu'en france les bibliothèques
universitaires ouvre autant moyenne 60
et une heure par semaine
le site de boulogne accueille ces
étudiants du lundi au vendredi jusqu'à
22h 30 et le samedi jusqu'à 20 heures
le site de saint quentin en yvelines
ouvre ses portes jusqu'à 20 heures en
semaine et le samedi jusqu'à 18 heures
ces deux bibliothèques s'organisent pour
assurer une permanence à chaque vacances
scolaires
sur le plan national un appel à projet
de 12 millions 7 sur 2016 2019 sera
lancé d'ici la fin du mois de février
par najat vallaud belkacem et thierry
mandon pour une mise en oeuvre du plan
bibliothèque est ouverte dès la rentrée
universitaire 2016
seconde partie de ce journal du vendredi
nous passons à l'essentiel de la semaine
le zapping de l'actualité locale depuis
lundi
vous en pensez quoi est-ce que c'est
indispensable de prolonger l'état
d'urgence
aujourd'hui je pense qu'effectivement
étant donné l'état de la menace
étant donné l'importance des mesures qui
peuvent être prises dans le cadre de
l'état d'urgence le président de la
république et le premier ministre ont
considéré qu'il fallait prolonger l'état
d'urgence d'autres moi j'y suis
évidemment pour ma part en tant que
préfet favorable cette élection interne
était surtout l'occasion de mettre en
marche le parti avant l'échéance
présidentielle et législatives de 2010
est lourde aux responsabilités parce
qu'elle a été oubliée
c'est de loin le plus grand parti de
france aujourd'hui structuré et remis en
marche depuis l'est depuis les
mésaventures de l'ump de l'époque et
c'est exactement ce que je trouve pas ça
végal du tout je trouve que le voiture
en leur voix et on verrait pas ça en
suisse par exemple
donc ici ça favorise les gens à
l'indiscipliné pas besoin d'une loi
puisque ça déjà cédé l'actuel tous les
moteurs sont périphériques le fond moi
je trouve que ça fluidifie ce trafic à
partir du moment où il roule pas comme
des fous j'ai pas oublier ce que je vous
ai dit c'est important que nous fassions
nous fassions tout ce que nous avons dit
donc d'ici la fin du mois de mars
je prendrai la décision sur les aires de
grand passage du sud des yvelines
entre temps je vais consulter encore
olivier carol entament leur journée
comme tous les jours mais depuis
quelques semaines leurs habitudes ont
changé
fini les traditionnels carnés vers ils
dégainent leur smartphone place aux pv
électronique avec ce type d'appareil
on a tous dessus on peut verbaliser car
quel type d'infraction les
stationnements com
quant aux routes saturées et vitesse
cinquante et un enseignant yvelinois
promu ambassadeur du numérique ont reçu
aujourd'hui leur clip de travail
à l'intérieur une tablette un vidéo
projecteur et un visualiseur par le
numérique on multiplie les entrées
possibles dans les savoirs scolaires et
on est plus attentif à la diversité des
apprentissages tel qu'il se joue dans
une classe avec des élèves qui
aujourd'hui grâce une approche parfois
plus ludique mais qui ne renonce pas aux
exigences scolaires pourront
s'approprier plus aisément des contenus
scolaires
adieu le papier place à la vidéo
étudiants et demandeurs d'emploi se sont
rendus à la maison de l'entreprise pour
en savoir plus sur le cv vidéo un outil
de plus en plus prisée qui intéresse
sabrine étudiant en droit à la recherche
d'un stage on est tous dit aux réseaux
sociaux vont tout le monde a une page
facebook donc je me suis dit pourquoi
pas faire quelque chose de concret et
plus professionnelle vis-à-vis du
recruteur gelée de betteraves boeuf
argentin une cuisine gastronomique sans
fioritures ici la carte des courtes on
trouve un menu unique qui change tous
les quinze jours
il travaille beaucoup sur les textures
on respecte également les saisons de la
pêche des viandes à l'ordre public mais
pour ça il ya des saisons une flotte de
27 keeper de neuf nationalités prouvera
le départ de la huitième édition du
vendée globe 2016 annonce a été faite à
paris pendant la cérémonie de
présentation de l'épreuve
parmi les concurrents de versailles et
tanguy de lamotte et éric bellion
car l'objectif sportif qui serait de
faire le tour du monde en 80 jours avec
ce bateau et avec le temps de
préparation que j'ai eu c'est quelque
chose de possible c'est un objectif
réaliste et coup d'envoi du vendée globe
en novembre ce sont à présent les jeunes
qui s'expriment sur l'actualité locale
et nationale comment ont-ils perçu et
les informations de ces derniers jours
la séquence est préparée par william
elle avec les élèves du collège des
soldes guyancourt
c'est quand par exemple que d'un emprunt
de la nourriture par exemple il ya des
enfants qui disent j'aime pas je mange
pas et du coup on mieux de conserver la
nourriture on les jette à la poubelle va
par exemple quand on de la nourriture
aux lieux de la ville de la jeter à la
poubelle et puis après je sais pas où
elle va mais là les chais on pourrait
très bien la mettre par exemple dans une
boite tupperware est là et la garde et
la manger le lendemain par une
expression qui dit ne pas avoir les yeux
plus gros que le ventre
ça veut dire voilà comme ça on a donc il
faut quand même prévoir ce qu'on va
manger d'abord donc voilà parce que
sinon après on va tout gaspillé donc
alors on comprend d'abord un petit peu
de nourriture et après on en reprend si
on a envie encore comme un mon père fait
on regarde combien né dans la famille on
achète ce qu'il faut de chacun et puis
voilà c'est tout j'ai vu rejeté des
cordons bleus des croque-monsieur des
pâtes des trucs comme ça
enfin des trucs qui se mange ça passe
par faire une liste canal frigo bien ce
qu'on aille à ce que n'a pas ce qu on a
pas mal mais sur une liste pour aller
faire les courses et ce qu'on aborde
justement l'écrit pas comme ça ça nous
permet de pas racheté en double et de ne
pas racheter non plus un stock à l'écran
surface en fait quand la nourriture sont
périmés de quelques jours même de
quelques heures parce qu'il disait
d'opération il ya des heures et des
dates il aimait de les jette
et puis mais des produits de la javel ou
des produits chimiques pour que les gens
comme les sdf ne viennent pas de
chercher les mêmes peinent à récupérer
pour se nourrir il ya des gens qui sont
dans la rue et qui sont dans le besoin
et au lieu de mettre de l'eau de javel
dans les poubelles et ben on pourrait
très bien les sortir pour que je puisse
en profiter
je ne sais pas peut-être qu'un jour on
inventera recyclea nourriture
peut-être cependant fait une bouillie
après on a fait un seul repas
un mot du programme de radio sensations
à présent nos confrères qui vous propose
ce week end en hebdo politique avec
huntsman nassourou conseil municipal
d'opposition à trappes également élu les
républicains la région tout cela à 28
ans à peine vous l'avez découvert
récemment sur notre antenne dans le café
politique
il évoquera avec nicolas kirillovitch
ses projets son actualité écouter cet
extrait il évoque son travail à la
région
on a un ensemble de décisions qui ont
été votées donc au bout de trois
semaines de mandat qui forme et quand
même l'armature de dudu campagne delà du
projet de valérie pécresse mais on a
d'autres qui vont arriver
c'est tout un an d'arbres rappelle que
le mandat ces six années donc là c'est
important de montrer que les engagements
qui est des prix sont tenus je pense que
c'est important dans la période en plus
convient qu'on peut re discuter du fond
du fond des propositions mais elles en
avaient largement parlé pendant la
campagne on le trouve sont des bonnes
propositions qu'on avance que c'est
dynamique et je pense que les prochaines
séances du conseil régional vont vous
confortez n'ont comporté en tout cas
dans cette décision et les retours sont
d'ailleurs très bon les gens sont
contents de dire on a voté il ya du
changement l'actualité locale revient
dès lundi en direct à 18h sur notre
antenne première diffusion 19h aussitôt
en replay sur le www.tsx.com 18 points
comme et voici quelques-uns des sujets
qui seront développés la fusion des
yvelines avec les hauts-de-seine les
choses se précisent avec la création ce
vendredi matin ce vendredi 5 février
d'un établissement public de coopération
entre les deux départements les enjeux
les conséquences ce sera en détail dès
lundi et puis le parc de thoiry c'est du
loisir va rouvrir ses portes après la
période hivernale le 13 février nous
verrons les nouveautés qui vous
attendent vous retrouverez juste après
ce journal mélanie poquet pour le 7-8
week end avec les idées sorties et
loisirs pour les prochains jours et
sachez que dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi c'est le super bowl la finale du
championnat américain de foot us pour
l'occasion lé templiers d'elancourt
s'associe à un restaurant sur les
clayes-sous-bois de 22h à 5h du matin
les courageux vont assister à la
retransmission du match sur écran géant
avec un show déchire lillers et des jeux
de pronostics également écouter est
laury fournier c'est la coach des
cheerleaders justement de ce club
organisatrice de l'événement monde veut
venir c'est vraiment une ambiance
funk monde s'amuse c'est bonne bon bon
vivant manger bon hamburger on regarde
un bon match et voilà y'a pas de prise
de tête
c'est à l'américaine à l'américaine on
rappelle que le match dure quand même
plusieurs heures c'est jusqu'à 5 heures
du matin c'est la fin de cette édition
du vendredi 5 février excellent week end
notamment beau courage à ceux qui vont
suivre ce super bowl reprise de direct
lundi 18h